hello I want to thank the organizers for
the opportunity to present about the
regulatory aspects and considerations
for high content diagnostic tests I want
to also thank all of you who joined to
start with some housekeeping items if
you do have any questions and if they
come up during the presentations during
the presentation just press that little
Q&A button that's on your left i think
the bottom left and please feel free to
submit them during the talk and i will
try to address them as soon as the
presentation is completed as a way of
introduction my name is Yvonne I tell
Jack I'm working in the office of in
vitro diagnostics and Radiological
health which is all I are for short this
is the FDA's office that we've used and
approves for marketing diagnostic tests
I will lay out some of the FDA's current
thoughts and a value on evaluation of
high content tests and i will be using
some specific examples and mainly
focusing on next-generation sequencing
which has been a topic of many talks in
this during this conference so far from
what I've seen and I'm hoping that this
will give you an overview of the high
content test policies we are working on
at FDA I do have to disclaim it since
there are no FDA cleared or food
next-gen sequencing tests at this point
in time although very much in
development what I am presenting today
is still preliminary and there is no
finalized at the a policy for evaluation
and regulation of these deaths just yet
we do encourage anybody but interest in
submitting this type of novel clinical
diagnostic tests or platforms to come in
letterpress a pre-submission to our
office so we can discuss your particular
test and platform and you can
discuss it but the NBA team that will
actually review it and you can get the
most current advice my plan in this
presentation is to give you a high-level
overview of FDA in vitro diagnostic
regulation some kind of FDA 101 if you
like and then i will get down to some
specifics applicable to high content and
actually specifically NGS test I will
compare and contrast some of the main
points in a DA review for in vitro
diagnostic tests in general and then
with the questions that are specifically
related to evaluation of NGS tests so
starting with this FDA 101 what you see
on this slide is the regulation which is
a part of the law and its defining FDA
jurisdiction over regulating in vitro
diagnostic tests now diagnostic tests
are in the US are regulating as a device
and there are parts of the regulations
for diagnostic tests are part of device
regulations if you are looking at this
regulation it encompasses different
types of you can put under clothes
really diagnostic testing because it's
talking about the cure and mitigation
and Prevention of disease oh so then on
this slide are listed parts of
regulation that Starling FDA how we
should look at i/b/e/s and this is
actually the same regulations as for
devices in general so we are supposed to
evaluate safety in effectiveness of any
new test if you're if you look at these
definitions of both safety and
effectiveness you can see that they are
pretty broad so FDA has some freedom
within these to establish the best
policies and requirements for a
particular device or particular test
type
so as I'm sure a lot of people in the
audience of well aware there are a
number of different ways that can look
at the genomic tests in particular so
here I kind of categorize these tests in
two very broad categories if you look at
these two big bullet points and
categorize categorizing them in single
analyte tests for example a simple test
for just one gene or you can have
multiple X tests or multiple marker
tests which are testing either a number
of genes or number of mutations in one
gene or a number of microorganisms we
just had the approval but that was mass
spec not DNA testing of 137
microorganisms so you can think of
next-gen sequencing as the ultimate
multiplex testing really so what's
listed also in this slide are arrays and
as an example that you can think of a
rate based copy number analysis this is
a common technology for a copy number
variation or CMD detection American
College of medical genetics or ACMG
recommends see a race egh as first-line
Diagnostics for abnormalities such as
developmental delay this more features
congenital anomalies and so on so
looking at this slide there are a number
of abia cleared or approved tests for
both of these categories of genetic
tests so both single and multiple marker
and I listed some example claims in this
life so do we don't have a lot of
experience with regulating these types
of tests okay so let's focus on high
density high content tests and let's
focus in particular on NGS
sequencing-based tests FDA has cleared a
number of multiplex tests and sold as I
mentioned before so that's not that new
so how are these NGS based tests
different from other genetic or genomic
test
that have been at the a cleared so far
well first these technologies have been
developing and changing extremely
rapidly in the last few years and I'm
sure I don't have to tell people of
we're listening that if you're looking
at the whole system from getting a
clinical sample through preparing and
testing it software for analyzing data
reporting back results different parts
of the system are manufactured by
different manufacturers and
manufacturing them may require very
different expertise and then more
importantly with genomic sequencing
unlike little bit multiple steps where
you have predefined variants or
predefined microorganisms or analyte
you're looking at and again we have at
the approved test that tests dear
genomic test talking about genomic test
sixty plus possible mutations in one
gene or 20 flights different
microorganisms so tests like sequencing
unlike those will provide unlimited
results and some or many of these may
have never been seen before so these
results so how can you assess the
clinical significance of these results
and then additionally how can you
evaluate analytical performance of all
different possible outputs and
understand that the results will report
are analytically valid so we do like to
put the issues we need to address apt
for public discussion with the experts
in the specific field and seems we have
been doing a lot of these meetings and
public discussions and more and more
lately to start addressing some of the
questions related to mention sequencing
we held a public meeting about two years
ago little over two years ago in summer
of 2011 and there is a link to all the
information related to that meeting at
the bottom of this slide in blue it's a
little small this meeting brought
together many of the pioneers and top
experts in the NGS field at that time
two years
including academics government
manufactures clinical labs professional
organizations etc in short we asked FDA
has asked a lot of questions and we put
for some suggestions for evaluation and
what we received back were mainly more
questions again there was two years ago
not too many solutions on how to
evaluate the performance of these tests
but since then over the last few years
many of the answers to the questions
that we have discussed at that meeting
have been slowly falling into place and
many of the presentations actually today
and yesterday were addressing some of
those so i will present some of these
solutions in the course of this talk so
on this next slide i am listing for you
the main parts which fda leave you in
order to understand the performance of a
genomic test and i will briefly cover
some of these bullet points in the next
few slides but i do not go through all
of them at the bottom i'm providing a
link to the webpage where we are listing
all fda-approved or clear the nucleic
acid based tests and from that link you
can pick the test that you may be
interested in and you can go to the
pages for any individual approved test
and you can see there the summary of the
test performance so for every diagnostic
test that is at the approved or have you
clearly published the summary of the
information be reviewed again it's just
a summary it's not all the line data and
not all the raw data not all the data
that we've reviewed by the summarized
information and this is very transparent
information you can see the performance
of the test so you can see what works
what doesn't work and what were the
studies that we're done ok so i listed
different parts of the submission on the
previous slide and i want to start with
the intended use so when fda reviews
test we start by looking at what is what
is just going to be used for what are
the claims
and those claims may be very general or
they may be very specific as in this
particular example so this specific
example this is intended use for the
first at the approved test in so-called
Ivy DMI a category which stands for in
vitro diagnostic multivariate index
assay it's kind of a retired category
right now but and basically this is the
test that measures multiple analytes and
and puts together the results in the
multi markers signature that would be
kind of a colloquial definition the main
parts of the intended use of the tests
are as you can see in these little
bubbles the analyte tested that the
intended use population to be tested
which is very important than many times
forgotten and what are the indications
for use and then so the types of studies
to evaluate certain tests will all
depends on a claim and all depend on the
claim in the intended use and somewhat
it would be somewhat dependent on the
technology that test is going on so what
would you want to know about the
diagnostic test performance it's it's
pretty simple really and straightforward
do you want to know that there are tests
analytically measures what you think it
does and got that it does it accurately
and you also want to know that your test
results correlates with the clinical
condition you're testing so this next
slide is listing analytical studies that
we normally evaluate in order to
understand the performance of a new test
and the studies listed here are not
limited to any type of in vitro
diagnostic tests their general studies
for evaluation of any IBD where the
specifics come into play is when you're
looking at details of each of these
studies as they relate to a particular
test so in the next few slides are the
highlight some of the performance
evaluation parts that may be challenging
or different or a next-gen sequencing
from the way we have been traditionally
evaluating
performance of the diagnostic test so
you can use the link in the window a few
slides ago in slide 8 to see what
performance studies need to be submitted
to have be in order for specific tests
to be cleared or approved for and you
can see all these various various
studies in device summaries so I will
not go into those details here but again
I will just try to highlight what what's
different for NGS test what's specific
for them so starting with non NGS
genomic test right so starting with
accuracy one on copy analytical studies
that may be very different from what we
have been asking in the past its
accuracy to set it up they slide
highlights some of the parts of accuracy
studies that are normally required for
molecular but molecular diagnostic tests
in general so for mbas emissions
analytical accuracy of a new test is
generally evaluated by comparing new
test results to results of some accepted
reference method for example for genetic
tests in many cases bi-directional
sequencing or Sanger sequencing has been
regarded as a gold standard method to
compare to there are also cases very new
test results have to be compared to a
clinical truth because there is no good
gold standard or reference methods or
there is no good comparator in order to
assess accuracy we generally require
multiple realm clinical samples for
every output of the test now why is that
why multiple samples for every output
and I'm still talking if you're not is
that the notice at the top still talking
about genomic tests in general not
necessarily NGS or high content test so
in this table you can see results of a
made-up multiplex test consisting of 23
alleles or you can imagine these as as
being different genes in cancer panel or
you can imagine these as being different
viruses in the respiratory disease they
know for example so the total positive
agreement of the test if you
at the top where it says total is almost
ninety nine percent however if you do
baby look down at a little 22 it has
much lower accuracy than others and only
about sixty seven percent and if you are
reporting this allele or if this is a
completely separate virus for example
you need to know that I'll show you jazz
the accuracy of the whole test which is
ninety-nine percent would be misleading
for this particular result which is only
sixty-seven percent so of course in I
will elaborate a bit more later we
cannot require this kind of evaluation
for next-gen sequencing based tests in
most cases but many times you cannot
even predict let alone adequately
evaluate every single output of the
next-gen the sequencing tests so how can
we assess the accuracy of NGS based
tests and suggested approach is to
select a subset of markers such as the
ones listed here in those three the
small bullet points so analytic
analytically challenging markers from
relevant disorders redundant sequencing
sequences spanning the genome etc and
then if we evaluate the performance of
these in order to of you can infer the
performance of the whole platform from
their performance of course this opens
many other questions and some are listed
on this slide including what would be an
appropriate comparative methods i've
been coming back to that over and over
again Sanger sequencing all possible
outputs of the test as a comparator will
be hugely expensive so it's not feasible
and in some cases it would be inadequate
and it may not be the right compared if
you think back of the base egh are from
some of microarrays we've been trying to
figure out the right compared comparing
our methods there too and they
have been coming up with a composite
comparator and method consisting of
meditation karyotype other methods qpcr
micro great consensus can be considered
so so there are ways to find some kind
of consensus or some kind of the best
reference method but so this slide gets
down to a little bit more specific if we
get down to that and if we're evaluating
a specific NGS baked sa best current
recommendation for assessing accuracy
for a targeted essay or relax let's
think of specific fan of cancer genes
for example this would this approach
would consist of consists of three parts
so the first one sequence clinical
samples that represent the intended use
population the second part sequence
procured samples that are adequately
representing variation types that are
part of piace for example small in dells
SMBs etcetera large deletions whatever
is a part of the test and the third part
sequence some well characterized
reference samples with known consensus
sequence deposited in a vowel curated
public database and you can assess error
rates across different applicants from
that of course there are many other
questions that come with that but it
it's probably a good start this slide
lists some of the criteria considered
for analytical evaluation somewhat like
the King see metrics before one can
consider it as results are valid in the
first place a lot of these came from God
and a lot of research and it was work
that they pioneering work they have done
there and they kind of just looked at
that for example things to check include
transition versus transversion ratio
number of expected calls allelic
attractions things like sequencing depth
for a specific application type level of
coverage necessary to make accurate
calls
completeness uniformity of coverage
these are all things that need to be
determined and validate we do not
necessarily expect perfect performance
it is important to understand though
what the performance is and which
regions are problematic to call and
which regions can be called perfectly
and we know some regions are difficult
to sequence i think somebody presented
today about ten percent of the genome
has not been sequence really yet with
any of the current technologies it is
reasonable to expect different
performance in different regions some
regions are harder to sequence some are
easier some cannot maybe be sequenced
yet I want to mention that you know a
lot of base has been also covered in
some of the public aid recent
publications that came from about
through love at last last year or so and
least there is a recent good newest
guideline most recent guideline is from
ACMG which was published less than a
month ago july twenty fifth on clinical
lab standards or NGS so these are for
the labs but a lot of this is a very
useful information but so this slide
lists very general precision study
requirements these would be applicable
to any IBD so we're talking any IVD
encoding NGS because what what you see
here is very general precision status
should assess major sources of
variability and include all analytical
steps of the assay as applicable and I
will not dwell much more of that if
somebody has questions we can discuss so
I want to move instead to the clinical
performance generally when there are
well established links such as
genotype-phenotype correlation said via
has been accepted relevant literature
professional societies recommendations
etcetera and we have not been asking
test manufacturers to reprove clinical
significance in the event that we also
to speak however there are many cases
when there is not enough in from
nation and that in those cases we would
likely require a clinical study to
establish some kind of clinical study
maybe not necessarily a clinical trial
to establish clinical correlation so the
question is how can this what has been
what has been used so far how can this
apply to NGS test I want to start with
saying that in the spring of 2012 ACMG
issued recommendations on scenarios when
to use genomic sequencing and especially
whole genome sequencing clinically and
these are listed on this slide so how
can we built on what we have been asking
in the possible clinical validation and
then the various recommendations from
the Society's like what I've mentioned
so what we have had in the past is we
have either in some cases relied on
published literature and how can we try
to put in place some kind of reasonable
interpretation system for high content
test like NGS and maybe news what's
existing in the public domain so one
thing that we have heard from clinical
experts during public discussions of
cytogenetic erase that i've mentioned
several times is that human and expert
interpretation is still critical in
these cases and you've heard that over
the last two days if you listen to any
of the presentations how much of the
interpretation is and is manual so that
should definitely be taken into
consideration when devising review
policy for next-gen sequencing test so
the interpretation of human expert
interpretation more general there have
been numerous private and public efforts
to build what you can call clinical
great databases and these can be used
then or labs are using them in
putting all this vast information
resulting from NGS now the problem is
that a lot of these efforts have
unfortunately for various many very
legitimate reasons been silent and there
is a need for these databases to talk to
each other and a need to build a unified
resource of clinically relevant variants
so a number of work groups are currently
trying to push such database for genetic
variations and kind of unified database
in these groups include ACMG which has
been very active in this field National
Human Genome Research Institute
international collaboration for clinical
genomics or I ccg also very active in
both arrays and next-gen sequencing now
and others I want to mention
specifically ncbi's clean bar which may
be the common database for depositing
the data on which clinical
interpretation can then be built upon in
many people this has been live from
clinvar has been live since April and
many people are depositing data both
clinical labs and researchers so if
successful we see a clinical grade
database as an important part of
clinical validation for MDA submissions
to and depending on the specific test
and depending on the specific indication
desk manufacturers may not need to
additionally approve clinical
significance beyond what's in the base
database but that will be again test and
indication specific and I will elaborate
some more on database efforts a bit
later but before that I want to go to
the last part of FDA review and that's
test labeling or packaging sir if you
will which according to the label and
regulation which is listed on this slide
it requires this regulation requires not
just instructions how to perform a test
that's not the whole labeling the
labeling according to this regulation
who needs also to list the summary of
test performance once the test is FDA
approved or cleared we forced as
mentioned before summary or reviewed
performance on the web now this line has
two links two on the top to any
fda-cleared test and on the bottom to
any at the approved test which is when
you have to submit a PMA in those cases
you can access both FDA generated
summary of the test performance but also
you can access manufacturers original
labeling so again through these links
you can access summarized performance of
any FDA cleared or approved test and all
this is publicly displayed so in summary
so far of what I've described is what me
with you and basically I was talking
about evaluation of the test performance
and like some specifics of what we are
thinking about the NGS test performance
so I was talking again both in general
and kind of gave you the law 101 and
provided some specifics now in the
second part of the talk I want to move
two possible ways to regulate these
tests some standardization efforts that
are on the way and collaborative
initiatives again before moving to that
second part in this slide I'm extracting
some of the most frequent challenges we
encounter and this is not just with NGOs
based tests but really did evaluating
the performance of any novel I duties
RVD in general many of these challenges
will probably look very familiar and
they include finding clinical samples to
value the performance figuring out the
best comparator to understand what
results of the better results of the new
tests are accurate and also they said as
I mentioned before with a race egh this
can include some very constructive ways
of putting together some kind of
composite preference and then also there
is a lack of knowledge about the
clinical validity and significance okay
so let's look at all the different parts
or
modules if you are well off angiosperms
and tests and probably many people
listening are well aware that many of
these modules shown here is still very
rapidly changing and developing and that
definitely applies to pre-analytical
parts which is your top left box and
also today of data analysis software
which is really rapidly developing so
this is your third box on the bottom box
on the left excuse me for example of
let's focus on the analysis part so most
platforms use past q as many of you know
for base calling and quality now in many
cases these programs are somewhat
different and their platform specific
actually one class Q is not the same as
the other pass key so the most commonly
used variant files on the other hand
seems to be evolving as we speak to so
we're talking V CFG DCF genome variation
format or gdf some of these may not be
the best suitable clinical needs many of
them really developed from research and
may also work better some of these may
work better with outputs from some some
of the platforms than others so there is
a need to standardize at least some of
these formats to LA 12 our data exchange
between different platforms and software
and achieve some kind of some level of
interoperability help level 7 or hl7 is
organization that is involved in
development of international healthcare
informatics interoperability standards
in there is a group currently working on
hl7 healthcare IT data standards for
clinical genomics actually so if we
focus okay so let's go back to this
middle box the what I marked in red if
we focus on sequence generation and
detection part these platforms have
actually reached some stability and some
of them are being manufactured under
gmps actually so we already discussed
earlier some possible ways of value
performance of NGS sequencers especially
accuracy but i wanted to dwell a little
deeper into some of that how to not
regulate these so if we built on this
previous slide and think about the whole
system and all these modules in general
the way FDA reviews diagnostic tests
starting from a sale it's starting from
a sample taken from the patient all the
way through pre-analytical parts
instrumentation and as a software to the
result however at that meeting that I
mentioned two years ago that happened
two years ago there are many suggestions
that in the case of NGS we should
actually look into some ways of
decoupling a platform from the test and
perhaps regulate them separately and I
have to say that we are seriously
considering some ways to do this we are
trying to create a pathway for maybe
getting instruments cleared without a
specific indication and then getting
essays approved will be easier on the
instrumentation that already has
established performance is under
manufactured under GMP's design controls
etc so we are looking and that's what's
listed on this slide at regulating these
tests in both ways actually so
classifying just the platform and we
have some possible presidents for that
and the other way would be regulating
the whole system or specific specific
assets that are intended for specific
indications that can be put on the
platforms that are may be cleared
separately I've mentioned several times
of the different public meetings and
protects the input from the experts so
we haven't been working in the vacuum we
haven't been trying to figure this out
in the vacuum we have been collaborating
for a couple of years now both within
FDA and then across government agencies
bit academia professional societies but
talking to clinical labs and others
on a number of standardization efforts
to try and leverage various existing
efforts and expertise and to try and
help and smoother transition of these
new technologies to the clinic while
still ensuring the accuracy of the
results and also transparent test
performance so what's listed on this
slide there are many efforts actually
listed on these slides and among them on
this slider and among them I want to
mention several CDC led initiatives
these have been actually instrumental in
developing some of the standardization
over the last several years and they
resulted in published recommendations
next next opt to as well as information
about possible reference material get RN
program also clsi or clinical lab
standard standards institute has been
working on developing a consensus
guidelines for clinical sequencing which
is almost finalized from what i know and
should be also very helpful once
available and i've mentioned already the
ACMG guidelines recent ACMG guidelines
publication which is also i understand
publicly available from an NC mg website
but i do wanna okay next slide i want to
highlight actually three standardization
standardization initiatives first one we
are working that we are a part of we are
working with nest to develop human
genome reference materials for NGS that
will allow both the FDA as always
destined platform developers to
understand how their systems work on the
well-characterized consistent material
george church actually mentioned this
material in his talk yesterday we have
we will be using some of the his PGP
samples that are well consented samples
for for this effort this collaboration
is expected to help standardize
high-throughput sequencing for clinical
applications in facilitate development
of safe and effective regulate
it's diagnostic applications the second
initiative i want to mention is a cdc
led efforts to address non-standardized
software formats for use in the clinic i
was talking about fast q and VCF formats
and different different other formats so
this initiative should help make data
coming from various sequencers
interchangeable and easier to understand
and compare so this effort is also on a
way and lastly a1a emphasize that we
strongly support the development of a
clinical great database and in the next
few slides I will try to elaborate on
some of the issues encountered for the
photo database specifically well you
have seen the same slide earlier but now
I will spend some time over the next few
slides focusing on this last part which
is interpretation of the results and I
will talk about the database role and
beyond beyond what I already described
ok so this unified database that I've
mentioned several times now when we are
referring to what you can call clinical
great database that we can also use at
FDA what does this mean first there
would have to be an appropriate data
repository and I've mentioned before
clean bar is very good candidate for
that on top of which all the other
elements can be built that data then
need to be curated to see where it
supports clinical significance there are
some repositories of clinical trial data
actually currently the works by some of
the groups now having political trial
data is nice because there's so much
control in generating it however about
this that's great work
trial data is available and it is great
to be able to utilize this enormous
amount of information that is stored
from those trials we cannot
realistically expect to have such
controlled studies in most cases so
people are looking at alternative ways
to use somewhat less standardized data
to learn things about not just test
significance but also things like drug
interactions I want to make clear that
FDA is not looking at building a big
database internally with all the efforts
already underway and all the accumulated
expertise in places such as NCBI for
example in various a CFG and other led
efforts for journal and related
variations having yet another database
effort would not make much sense so what
we are looking at is to help what seemed
to be the most promising efforts that
are either either started or they're on
their way or it's starting just now and
what they're looking to it is and that
in that process we get out of these
databases the information that we and as
developers can use as a part of clinical
test evaluation some questions to start
from include so where do we start when
we are looking what do we want in the
database right so these questions may
include surveying what may be the gaps
in current practices for contents or
formats of existing or developing
databases we can also look at whether
there is some type of curation and how
thorough maybe I was talking mentioning
before a manual expert interpretation
and curation and that's still the case
we can compare levels of evidence that
EDA would typically except to the levels
that are applied in database curation it
seems very reasonable and plausible
there can be a stepwise approach to both
whatever is the raw data collection as
well as levels of evidence
at the bottom of this slide I listed
some of the current database efforts
underway and where the main drivers
behind those four different types of
variation soldier blinds somatic
microorganisms I didn't list the drivers
there so that that would be ncbi i think
also evi indefinitely FDA's sips and
which center for foods are working
together there some options that are
being discussed are better it is more
practical and realistic to have one
centralized database or perhaps
federated approach would be more
feasible and may be better suited to
diverse needs and loss if building an
international database with a range of
stakeholders that can use it for their
specific purpose if the approach is some
kind of federated database there would
presumably be some kind of apps on top
of these various separate databases that
would interconnect them and be able to
fold the data that someone may need for
their specific clinical use another
question often discussed is the need for
different different evidence levels and
to store not just clearly clinically
validated data because there's so much
more to learn from additional data that
may or may not eventually ascend to some
type of clinical actionable level
additionally having a feedback loop to
deposit or correct the information we
learned more about since first placed in
the database or in some expert group
curates it is very important and should
be built in I mentioned already the need
to not restrict data to only clinically
actionable this need for not restricting
is actually applicable through all
different levels of the possible
database not just having different
record rigor of curation it should be
however very clear what is in the
database what is at each level if you
are having different levels and how
validated and curated it is there seems
to be a general agreement that both
research in
from data can be deposited from what I
know as long as it's noted or delineated
where the data comes from and with the
understanding of the level of validation
and controls next question that ncbi has
been wrestling a lot is the question of
some type of unified data formats i've
mentioned that quite so very the naming
conventions are similar issues to be
able to analyze together data coming
from there is disparate sources there
helping some successful attempts
actually and I think a scope I love
database maybe one to create platforms
or applications that can take in very
different North standardized data types
and consolidate them but this was not
any of these pilots from what I know
were not a genomic test data but this
possibility of using non-standard its
data mainly very important actually
since labs generating and submitting the
information may not have additional time
or resources at least at the beginning
to convert their data and sent to some
kind of standardized format additional
issues people are working on include
privacy issues especially collecting
data and information coming from
different entities different countries
different law that that would have
different laws so that that's important
and lastly I want to mention options
like cloud storage versus local servers
and what should be stored where are
these are increasingly considered so
where do we go from here well we are
working towards hopefully having some
fda cleared sequencing platforms and
tests in the near future it also might
be helpful we are thinking to publish
some some kind of points to consider
document so what points to consider when
evaluating next-gen sequencing based
tests for FDA submissions
many people have told us that would be
helpful helpful I want to say that we
are very interested in feedback from
other experts in the field and we are
very open to hearing suggestions and
criticisms if you think we've done
something right we it wouldn't mind
hearing that either but but definitely
we want to know about holes in our
approach and we would like to work in
overcoming it does I want to end it also
saying that if someone is considering
submitting high content test for their
clearance they encourage you to contact
at da early in the process and the with
that I want to thank you very much for
listening thank you very much for
joining I would be happy to take any
questions and on this slide also i'm
providing my email address so if i don't
know the answers to your questions so if
you want to contact someone at a DA
directly and you don't know who to
contact please feel free to contact me
and i can direct you to the right person
and i see there are some questions
coming in and also i think i need to add
a slide if you need CME credit go to
this web page ok let's look at the q and
A's now that's a okay no questions
available for this play even though
there were income questions okay well so
i think i can maybe wait for a second
but i do want to say again i want to
come back to this slide if you don't
have questions now or if you think of
some later or if you don't want to ask a
question publicly for whatever reason
please feel free to to contact me and if
i don't know the answer is
again I will try to I will make sure to
direct you to the right person because
we are very open to both feedback and
also to giving you feedback on whatever
your testes so if if there is no
questions if it's all clear I think our
load and the broadcast here